hi my name is ian russell i'm the
associate director of marketing at
dovetail genomics and
in this presentation i'm going to be
talking to you about expanding the hi-c
toolbox
and introduce you to some new
high-resolution approaches
that we have applied to diptone diploid
genome phasing
protein-directed chromatin architecture
mapping and more
in this presentation i'm going to give
you a brief introduction
into chromatin conformation capture just
so you're oriented
uh in terms of how that data is
generated and how to interpret it
and then i'm going to go into detail
about some of the new products that
we've launched and the applications
which you can use those for
there are a variety of methods for
chromatin conformation capture which are
depicted here
all of these methodologies share the
same core workflow that i'll walk you
through
on the left hand side what you can see
is a cross-linking step
this cross-linking step is designed to
cross-link
chromatin in situ and thereby capture
the 3-d conformation of the genome
in its natural state the next step is to
digest that crosslink chromatin
typically this is done using restriction
enzymes
in my cartoon here you can see that the
blue and the red molecules
which are found in close proximity may
actually be fairly distant
in linear space along the genome the
next
phase or step within the workflow is a
ligation
in which the pairs are ligated together
the cross link is reversed and the
output
is a chimeric molecule that can be
analyzed in a variety of different ways
the current methodology or the most
popular methodology today for doing this
is a process called high c in which the
readout of that chimeric molecule
is performed on the next gen generation
sequencing platform
in terms of interpreting the data what
one is
creating is a pair of reads or a read
pair
from the next gen sequencing library
that can then be mapped back
to the genome position if
those two pairs are
next to each other in linear sequence
space then they would fall
on the x-axis or that blue bar down at
the bottom
and the distance between the read pairs
in terms
of space separation it moves them
upwards on the y-axis so you can see in
my cartoon
here at the bottom there are three
different examples of how far a read
pair may
map on the genome position and where
that gets plotted within
what's called a contact matrix the
longest molecule or the longest distance
is up at the top and a
45 degree diagonal is drawn from the
position
of where one half of that repair maps
and where the other half of that read
pair maps to
a point that's up at the top the
intermediary
one which is depicted by the two dots
in the middle of the contact matrix
show an intermediary distance between
the two
parts of the chimeric molecule and then
there's an example of
a read pair where they are much closer
in proximity or in linear space to each
other
so this is the basic premise of a lot of
the data that i'm going to show you
later in the presentation
the way that it actually looks within
the data set
is not quite as clear as what i've
depicted there
and so here you're looking at the data
from two different chromosomes
typically there's very few read pairs
which are
resulting from ligations that are
interchromosomal
and you can see that it starts to build
up these triangular
shapes within the data that represent
regions
that are have a high probability of
being
in close proximity to each other and
i'll go into a little bit more detail
later in the presentation as to the
significance of that
what's clear is that one can use this
data to start to
uh arrange um the the order of fragments
uh through genome assembly um for
uh mapping purposes and i'll go into
that
in some subsequent slides here
now one unique approach at dovetail
genomics
is to move away from restriction enzymes
for that fragmentation process
the reason for doing this is that the
restriction enzyme approaches
are biased as depicted in these
graphs here what you're looking at with
the dotted
uh black line is the typical
distribution
of a shotgun library where the
target coverage is approximately 30x
you can see with restriction a single
restriction enzyme approach
you get a lot of bias
introduced into that data where a lot of
the genome is not covered very much at
all
and then there are regions which are
overly covered on the right hand side
by adding in additional enzymes for a
multi-restriction enzyme approach
you do address that to some extent but
you're still not approximating
what a shotgun library is capable of
and with the dovetail approach which
uses sequence independent endonucleases
we get very close to that shotgun
distribution which is
ideal both in terms of
coverage and the ability to use the data
in a multitude of ways
that i'll describe to you
secondly the dovetail approach provides
libraries of very high quality
there are three main ways of assessing
the quality
of a high c library the first one is the
number of valid repairs
that is the total percent total of the
library
that gives long range information
for the most part researchers are
interested in the cis read pairs and so
we look very closely at those
and what we're plotting here are three
different distances
distance buckets so reads that represent
interactions greater than
1kb in separation 20 kb
and 1 megabase and then lastly library
complexity
which is important in terms of
utilizing your sequence in the most
efficient fashion and as you can see
in the blue bars which depict a typical
dovetail library
we outperform both the multi-restriction
enzyme and the single restriction enzyme
approaches
so from this one can start to
apply high c to a variety
of different applications which prior
restriction enzyme approaches did not
support
so the detection and structural variant
sniff and indel genotyping genome
assembly and hassle type phasing
and lastly chromatin conformation and so
through the rest of my presentation
i'm going to introduce you to the
different products that we have
and how they can help you in terms of
addressing
those applications specifically the
first product i want to focus on is the
omni-c kit
this is a kit which is really being
designed to provide superior uniform
coverage and
mimics that shotgun library and it's
really the most flexible kit that
dovetail
offers the workflow is depicted on the
lower portion of the slide here
i'm just going to point out the major
differences from that core workflow that
i shared with you initially
the first one is in the cross-linking
step instead of a single class
cross-linker we use a dual-class linking
approach which helps to enrich in the
long-range interaction
in the second step the fragmentation uh
is performed
using a dna's one enzyme which is the
sequencing
independent endonuclease and then lastly
within the ligation step
we use a oligonucleotide bridge
depicted by the orange molecule there
that is biotinylated
and this is used to enrich for those
chimeric molecules of interest
as i showed you before the omni-c
approach does an excellent job in
eliminating that sequence bias that's
seen within the restriction enzyme
approaches depicted
in the top two tracks here so you can
see there are holes in the coverage
uh both with the single restriction
enzyme and the multi-restriction enzyme
approach
whereas omni-c provides that very even
coverage
uh that i was referring to and so the
net result of this
is to lower the sequencing costs
associated with a particular study
here we're modeling the coverage needed
to reach
30x over 80 percent of the genome
and with a typical shotgun library
that's somewhere in the range of about
41x
there is a slight tax with the omnic kit
one needs 51x in order to reach that
metric
but that represents a fairly minor
increase in the overall sequencing cost
with a major increase in the type
and amount of data that one is producing
in such an experiment
that can be uh hi-c has traditionally
been used for denover scaffolding
and you can see a typical approach here
where one uses a combination of
short-range
platforms such as illumina or pac bio
combined with the long-range information
that a hi-c library provides
in this particular example omni-c does a
very good job
or an equal job to standard hi-c
in terms of being able to reach across
those large gaps within a
particular assembly and enable the
ordering and orientation of those
fragments the major advantage to using
omni-c
in a scaffolding environment
is depicted on this slide
so what we see when we compare
omni-c snip discovery or snip genotyping
to shotgun
is a very similar sensitivity and
precision
and that is significantly above what one
is able to achieve with the restriction
enzyme hi-c approach
this is important because it opens up
the possibility
of phasing the data and here we show an
example
of running that data through a
pipeline called hapcut2 where
we actually exceed the number of
heterozygous snips phased
compared to shotgun have a very low
switch error rate
and can get to full 23 chromosomes
phased for a mammalian genome
or human genome and compared to a
restriction enzyme
approach where yes you can get to that
fully phased
assembly however the switch error rate
is four-fold higher
we've now applied this to the atlantic
bluefin tuna genome
and i'm not going to go into any detail
in terms of the data on this slide but
suffice it to say
that we were able to get
to 24 major scaffolds which is the
expected number of chromosomes for that
particular species
so this is working very well for us
switching gears just a little bit i did
want to share with you
the exploration of the data that we've
done around structural variants
here we're showing data for a human
breast cell line
as well as a control where we're looking
at specific
inversion deletion and translocation
events which we know exists within that
particular data set
and as you can see those are clearly
depicted or clearly detected within the
omni-c data
as shown by the
bow tie shapes that are at the lower
panel
of the slide here
lastly before i finish up on omni-c i
just wanted to point out the degree of
flexibility
that the assay provides we have
produced an ultra-low input protocol
which enables
going down to very small cell inputs
down to a thousand cells so that opens
up possibilities with small sample input
such as that coming from facts
experiments
and the ability to work with these
library types with
standard hybrid capture panels and so
here's some examples in terms of the idt
xgen lockdown the illumina true site
agilent sure select to name just a few
there
are directly compatible with the data
type that's coming out of the omni-c
library
now i'm going to switch gear uh into the
epigenetics world and talk about two new
products that were launched at the
beginning of this year the first one we
call the micro microc kit
and the second one which is a evolution
of that
is the high chip m a's kit
before i get into that let me just
quickly talk about epigenetics
specifically for those of you familiar
with epigenetics you're probably using
tools such as bisulfite sequencing chip
seek or ataxi
all of these look at the genome in a
very linear
sense so for bisulfide sequencing
which of the
bases are methylated
on a linear sequence for gypsy
which regions are bound by a particular
protein or for attack seek
which regions are open
and accessible to the the transposes
within that assay
what i hope i've started to convince you
with is genomes are not
organized in a straight line the human
genome is about three meters in length
and it gets
compacted down into a six uh
uh micron nucleus
and that is done in a very organized
fashion using
a series of uh hierarchical genome
conformation features which are depicted
here
at a high level we have chromosome
territories where the
different chromosomes are actually
isolated from each other within the
nucleus
when you break that down there are
features which are called
av compartments and these essentially
map to
compartments or regions of dna which are
active in transcription
also known as euchromatin or inactive
and highly compacted or heterochromatin
zooming in further within that there are
topologically associated domains and
these
typically cluster genes that are linked
in function
and then even finer than that are
loops which mediate transcription factor
interactions so promoter enhancer
interactions
and with each of these one is zooming
further and further
into the topology of the genome for a
standard hi-c
library to do this you start to hit
limits of the resolution
of that approach as well as to get down
to a 5kv
map as depicted on the right-hand side
there
that requires enormously deep sequencing
and so there's a significant cost
associated with that
so what we've tried to do with microc is
to address
those two challenges and the way we've
done that is to take the standard
uh omni-c kit which i just shared with
you
and swap out the enzyme for an enzyme
called micrococcular nuclease or mnase
this nuclease is sequence independent
it has an endonuclease activity as well
as an exonuclease activity
and the end result of digestion with
mnas
is that you get short fragments that map
to the nucleosome specifically
a major advantage of that as shown in
this particular slide here
is that we get a much improved signal to
noise
over standard restriction enzyme
approaches
so you can see going from a
multi-restriction enzyme approach to
microc
there's about fourfold increase
in the number of
um a point of evidence
uh within the microc data set and over a
single restriction enzyme approach
uh that's about 16 fold more so that
means
both the ability to discover more
as well as savings in terms of cost
from a sequencing standpoint in not
having to sequence as deeply
the other major advantage is
shown in the next slide here
where we have taken
a protein called ctcf which binds to dna
and defines a lot of the topology that i
described in that earlier slide
cpcf is
used to
structure the nucleosomes and what you
can see here is
for the high occupancy ctsc
sites we've mapped out the
sequence on plus or minus 1kb on either
side of that
and you can see in the data the mapping
of the nucleosomes directly here as
depicted
by the peaks and valleys so each of
those peaks within the blue
data set represents the position of a
nucleosome
where the chromatin or dna was protected
from the micrococcal nuclease
and the valleys are the linker sequence
between nucleosome
where the micrococcular nuclease has
digested it
and so with this you can start asking
questions about
nucleosome positioning within the
context of
various topological domains and features
the last part of my talk i'm going to
build upon
the microc workflow and introduce you to
the high chip
product high chip basically uses a
similar
chemistry for the fragmentation and
proximity ligation
but introduces an enrichment approach
using antibodies to enrich for sequences
bound by a specific protein of interest
so again we're cross-linking up front we
do our fragmentation
prior to ligation however we do a
chromatin immunoprecipitation
and then we go through the same steps
that i shared with you before
the data that one gets out of this is
shown
here where we're comparing the dovetail
high chip data for
the ctcf binding factor with
chip seek data and what you can see
first of all is that the data looks very
similar
in terms of where the ctsc
is binding to the genome as depicted
by the peaks in both the green and the
red
graphs there but the high chip
data contains long-range interaction
information
that is shown by the arcs below the
green line
the green graph and each of those arcs
represent
an interaction in three-dimensional
space between
different ctsc ctcf molecules
not only that we can zoom in to a
specific ctcf
binding site and what you can see is
that compared to the chipseek data
the positioning of the nucleosomes
within that data set
is extremely clear as depicted by
the the peaks and valleys as i shared
with in that previous slide
now this assay is very easy to get up
and
running in the lab we have a panel of
pre-validated antibodies that are
available for it
to get you going before i finish out i
just wanted to share
one perspective in terms of how one
might start
using these different products in trying
to understand various aspects of
gene expression here we're looking at an
omni-c data set where we've
mapped the different a and b
compartments as shown by
the orange and the red tracks there
labeled pc1
where they are positive above the line
is an a compartment where they're below
the line is a b
compartment what you can see comparing
brain to liver is
there are differences between the two
and those
map to specific changes in
methylation of the histones as well as
gene expression changes
so just to finish up here hopefully what
i've convinced you of
is there's a variety of different
dovetail kits
that are available all of which use
sequence independent
nuclear endonucleases to help
maximize the data that one is getting
from your studies to address
a variety of different applications
including structural variant detection
and intel genotyping genome assembly
apple type phasing
and genome conformation with that i'm
going to stop here thank you for your
attention
and would be very happy to address any
questions you might have